hi there's no need for an intro so I'm
not even going to bother with that I I
much rather talk about rollercoaster
tycoon 3 if only i actually built
something that I really like in this
episode so because basically last time I
talked about how I did not like the fact
that in this park was turning out to be
something that was very repetitive
perhaps and I wouldn't do many new
things and stuff like that so yeah me
being dumb I decided to build a station
in the style of the rest of the park
not realizing two things actually three
things probably actually two things
actually no let's count them as we go so
first of all there's the fact of course
that this would not look that I decided
to do it in the same style and that was
a bad idea then second of all it turned
out to be one of the oakley's it's not
really ugly I'm not gonna call it ugly
that's not very nice of me to say but I
I don't quite like it as much as I
wanted to and it didn't really turn out
into a building that's special in any
way I mean it's good but it doesn't it's
not very special it's not something
unique it's not something that I really
like so but yeah I'm basically and I
think that was two points yeah so I only
had two points but I don't know I still
don't like the building but I'm just
gonna show it and I'm just gonna keep
the building I don't want to build
things and then remove them I'm just
going to shape the environment around it
then I guess do something Rock work and
other things to make it actually fit
into the position it's at and stuff like
that one of the major problems that I
had with this building which is actually
going to be in a later part it's not the
stuff that I'm working on right now just
building the base right now the
foundation of it is the roof see the
base is actually something that I can
get done it's not something too hard but
the roof was something that I I I had to
mess around with a lot and I'm still not
too happy about the roof so I might
actually edit that while off-screen or
something like that i I do still love
the way that Serie G set works with
shyguys sets
and even with Brian just path sets for
the walls so that is really great really
love those pillows combined with shyguys
walls and some rocky textures for their
bases really like that and of course the
trims and all the other odds and ends in
zero-g set I mean not super G sets but
in that one set are actually something
that I really like using these windows
for example they're also great by the
way if you're confused about why I am
confused about this set it's because
this set is very confusing it's it's
called zero G's things but it's made by
station Jim jr. it's it's things made
for zero-g so the set is called several
G's things but it's kind of confusing as
to some point people kind of forgot who
made this set so that's where that came
from
now the cue is something that I also
need to pay more attention to I tend to
be very lazy with my cues I am
interested in architecture in landscape
design and I can't bother with all those
interior things I usually just place a
couple of railings of fences and then
call it a day which is a really bad idea
you should have real station gates and
stuff like that also the thing that I'm
adding right now is just to add
something to make the building not a
square because your building should not
be a square especially if it's baked
like this but anyway so for this stage
you know actually decided to do some
more things than I usually do and we'll
get to that eventually but it's still
not the most realistic thing ever that
beside though that site but the thing is
also I am NOT a coaster enthusiasts I
don't know if I've said this too much or
not enough yet but I'm not a coaster
enthusiasts I'm just in this community
for my love of architecture and the
flowers I'm actually known by some
people as that one guy who always does
the flowers and I don't know I know
stuff off rollercoasters because you
guys kind of taught me all that but I
still don't know too much I don't have a
damn how queues work I don't I don't
even like know like if you should have
those station gates at both sides and
I don't know this is something that I do
know though fountains are awesome and if
you have a little square then you can
always add a fountain in the middle but
not always but it always look it always
looks cool so yeah that's one of my
number one tips if you have what
concerning squares if you have a square
and there are many things you can use
for a square for example restaurants are
great for things like that but also a
fountain in the middle is just gorgeous
you can also add a pillar in the middle
with something like a sculpture on top
of it but building things like that is
kind of hard in roller-coaster country
and there aren't many pillows so
fountains are generally the way to go
the only thing that always annoys me is
the fact that everybody uses ralphie's
fountains and everybody uses the same
fountains so you just start recognizing
them and then it's just like a song
where as you recognize a preset and
you're like ah no screw that entire song
then automatically the entire song just
sucks I don't know that's just what I
think sometimes but anyway I just wanted
to add some path covers around the
fountain just for some more detail and
add some of those things around it so I
it it has path covers but I think it's
not really something that you usually
walk on though I do remember that from
City trips whenever we would see a
fountain we would just sit on it so that
works as well and yep what this fountain
also gives is that little I don't know
what to call it that little cliff face
with the path right there which I can
add rocks to and kind of look it kind of
looks pretty cool to me at least so I
like that and then on my always and
rocks to that or maybe even some
buildings uh no and yeah one of the path
cover tricks that I used in this park is
just mix to ground textures and add a
alpha texture add a Alpha texture above
that so for example take that take the
sand and take the rock blend them and
then add for example and offer brick
texture
so this set that I'm placing right now
is something that many people are
requesting and for all you people
request it I can't give it to you guys
basically there was a competition on
shyguys world hosted by toothpick which
was designed in put me and this other
guy called Jake we entered well
basically he built the coaster layout
and all that so he actually did more
work than I did he just went to me for
the foliage and stuff so we built that
and won the competition so I got this
set for it but if it was like no it's
exclusive set you may not give it to
anyone until design and input 3 comes
around which is November this year I
think so I was like ok 1 the set gave it
to many people and toothpick was all
angry and I was like oops so I can't
give it I I wish I could but we just
have to wait for a while for that and in
the meantime the station is kind of
nearing completion when it comes to the
base level also this is the part where I
actually add some random details that
controls stuff and something that I've
actually rarely done is actually
something that I discovered just because
I got some new sets I now got crates and
all that so I figured why not add them
and of course I went totally overboard
and and it creates some boxes and and
stuff like that everywhere and and
barrels and so PewDiePie Stefano mr.
chair so I kind of went overboard on
that shouldn't do that so obviously I
had to remove some of those things later
on but it's still something that's
pretty cool to have in your stations as
long as you have something that's wood
ish station details are definitely
something that I never realized you
should put in your stations but you
definitely should put in your stations
I'm definitely going to consider
interiors and interior design more from
now on so let's see what what's that oh
that's the this is this is where I
basically set sail to fail I think that
the first part is actually pretty good
this is where I had a good design in
mind and actually like this but the the
main problem is that later on I just
totally screwed this over
at some point I might actually redo this
entire thing I don't know how I don't
really know anything I just know that I
like the bass thing and I like these
side roofs but now this is the part
where it goes bad this is the part where
I make mistakes and I kind of want to go
back to but yeah that's something I
can't do also for me it's an extreme
like fest at the moment I don't know if
it really is it shouldn't be but anyway
so I just added all those poles and then
it just looked like a poor like first
but anyway that's it for this episode
thank you so much for watching and see
you in the next one